good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Tuesday we hope everyone is
settling nicely at their desks or on
their couch or wherever you are on this
bright Tuesday morning I hope for your
sake you're on your couch because that's
where I would be right now I'm so
jealous of anyone who's on their couch
right now I know but you know at this
time of year it's crazy because it's
crunch time it's the busiest time of
year for like working but I feel like
it's the time I get the most burnt out
like I'm running on fumes right now it's
also like it's that College mentality
like you come back from fall break you
have the most to do finals but all you
can really think about is you have five
weeks off coming up and like that's
where your head is that so like those
three weeks in between the two vacations
are like filled with so much treachery
but also the time where you're like just
on vacation mode the most yeah I don't
know I'm really struggling and like I
just in struggling to just stay on my
schedule you know what I mean I'm
struggling because I had two of odgersd
odors last night like I mean I'm not
gonna say what tequila soda and I have
the world's worst headache like I'm
turning into you but you know what I
think it is I actually have had this
situation before where I don't drink a
lot it like a fancy event but for some
reason whatever drinks are served in
like a fancy glass and it's like soda
water and tequila like those drinks give
me hangovers where it's like dirty
tequila shots from like the bottom of a
bar in the like middle of nowhere those
don't get me hungover it's a Felix you
drink fancy drinks when there like
waiters passing around drinks are always
so watered-down especially by the time
they get to you know Tula ice melts I'm
not talking about the potency I'm just
say something about those types of
drinks like in a classy affair gets me
more hungover and I'm not even going
over I feel like fine physically is just
like I have a pounding in my head and
like I'm getting an optical migraine
like my eyes hurt damn hey you see it I
know it's terrible give it another year
sis we were supposed to have Brian on
the show today but he is broken down and
hungover and I'm not one to force and I
totally I'm the type of person like if
you cancel on me like I totally
understand cuz odds are in the near
future like I will be canceling on you
too yeah and now now I have a
cancellation in my back pocket right but
we're gonna recap the tdg Awards because
they were so fun so premium second
annual the points guy Awards we're the
best in travel and credit cards was
celebrated and podcasts and podcasts yes
because we were there I had a great time
we had a great table yeah Dorinda and
Margaret joseph´s were at our table I
like have such a special
corner of my heart for Margot Joseph and
Joe and super Joe was there and I just
like I just really feel like a special
way about them like I think she's such
like a real person
totally and I just have like only
positive and like loving things to say
but really I see her like I'm just so
happy to see her and honest I just want
to like Nestle my head in her bosom it's
truly like I know people always say this
it is a pleasure to see her it's an
absolute pleasure like I feel pleasured
not in a weird way also I said exit
Dorinda Andrea has come on the show but
I've never really socialized with her
she's such a nice lady yes she is
gorgeous gorgeous she came on the show
like three years ago now and she sat
down she was like how fun was that when
can I come back I'm like excuse me you
can let her come back with anytime
anyplace anywhere there were a lot of
housewives there I didn't see or get to
meet Deandra which I was really upset
him I saw Deandra I didn't get to meet
her because she's never come on this
show so we don't have that point in
connection and it was like a dangerous
choice do I say hi do I not say hi and I
figured like not saying I won't meet
hugs
well cross paths perfectly and then and
then it starts yeah that's how we saw
Phaedra the worst thing you could go up
to someone and say oh my god hi like I
love you I do a podcast oh my god where
we show off their outsides like if
someone said like nope no that's a
turn-off we have to be cool you know
yeah cool so unfortunately we didn't get
to chattin I didn't get to talk to Kate
Chastain either
um because they were at a different
table but I saw Phaedra in fade for just
like justice for Phaedra I say Phaedra
is the points girl she is every TPG
event coming up and showing us the og
like a housewife who started going to
TPG events before like it was cool to
know 100% Ramona came with Avery and I
were so funny like they are just the
timing to attack she's probably like so
fun to have Ramona is your mom yeah and
they just take the town together
they're like socialites they are yeah
they are they aren't like social yes
they are like um who else was there lots
of people I haven't seen in a while joey
camasta who i always have a special
place in my heart for he is so funny and
Heather was there and Heather opened the
show and I was really caught off guard
because they were like Ryan Kelly and it
was like a skit where Heather came out
dressed as Brian Kelly I just like
wasn't expecting to see Heather I didn't
know that she was gonna open the show it
was hysterical generic she was so funny
who else was there
oh the earth pet was there and I
obviously captured a very precious
moment where Derek was filming Claudia's
um time on stage for his camera
and he never posted it right now it's
just like right sitting in his phone
like waiting to be rewind over and over
again on the camera yeah yeah not on
Instagram by the camera just really
really cute so supportive he was like
obviously like Ben wasn't even filming
no totally she'd been film the whole
thing I was laughing at all my jokes I
was listening to Ben's video of myself
and like Ben was like I could I told him
like if you don't laugh like corporate
events are so tough you know hi there
it's the definition of a tough crowd
it's a tough crowd except last night it
really wasn't it everyone was like
really young they got my jokes they were
like the drinks were flow and it was
easy but it's always I get more nervous
to do like a corporate event than I
would to do just like a show at the
Beacon well not the weekend but like a
lot like I had a thousand person show
yeah it's a tough room but you did an
amazing job you were so funny I tried so
hard it was spectacular it really is um
it's an honor you know just to be
nominated yeah
and it's an honor just to be there and
learning about points and travel and
seeing like all of the upgrades that I
don't get in the big wigs and the big
wigs it's a roomful of bigwigs like so
many wigs you guys it was crazy
so many [ __ ] Carly Rae Jepsen
performed and she is just such a treat
she was incredibly talented I was really
surprised because Ben was like she was
totally lip singing I'm like actually
she totally wasn't she had such charisma
and again I'm sure it's difficult to
perform for a corporate crowd when it's
like no one's like on drugs and you know
like people at carly Rae Jepson concert
she's a gay icon it's like I'm sure it's
incredibly lit yes so she's not used to
like a more subdued crowd but the crowd
really turned up for carly rae jepsen
they respected the hell out of her and i
was actually really surprised she put
six songs and i thought it would only
know two but i did four but i thought i
would know all and i didn't know one
Juliette oh yeah
Julianne actually yet oh and then one
other song that she said she wrote about
her cat but she was a cutie and I really
enjoyed the performance and I didn't
think anyone could top last year's bebe
Rexha because she really surprised me
the most a with her vocal tones be again
with how many songs I didn't realize she
was featured on and three just like
she's so cool and fun and I just like
loved her but Carly Rae Jepsen was a
great great great act yeah all in all it
was a great night it really was my head
is something I'm just it took so much
out of me getting ready for that event I
don't know I can't even tell you maybe
it was because my tik-tok but probably
I made a TED talk this morning to follow
us you guys girl with no job and Jacki
secured the handle at Jackie O I'm
Jackie I want a talk so like they're
giving me the respect that I deserve
because they do have verified it's
really exciting I think I went like a
little viral on tick tock because one of
my videos has 70,000 views and it's like
not even that funny
don't let it flop y'all I did one today
can I can you watch it I'll watch it
okay it's like really creative I got in
on the trend have you seen it been
seeing the one that's like oh I said I
know I know I know I have to see it okay
it's like a trend where it's like you
stand with your back towards the camera
and you like write all these
misconceptions about you oh yeah oh I
can't wait to Y yeah it's [ __ ]
hilarious I can't wait except I have a
typo like in I'm really stupid I mean
you know what I spelled wrong of course
you do and you want to know why I he'd
you know what I spelled wrong shoes
tik-tok stop honey I see with the most
typos in the world and I say that for
not like working on it because you don't
and honestly it's getting crazier you
sent me a text today that was
straight-up gibberish but what I sent
you I knew that it was like totally
[ __ ] up and it was on purpose because
I wanted to convey how incredibly flat
screen shot used anyway I understand
that's fine but like the other night she
wrote in our chat like what she meant to
say what she should have been looking
for this and sure what shows should I be
looking for this so the question - make
sense - no one answered her she hopped
some in the morning okay thanks everyone
your question didn't make sense but I
didn't realize I had a typo why didn't
someone let me know like Clara I'd be
like what do you mean or question mark
usually you like send something with a
tie boats star corrected but and you
didn't work on yourself and your typos
and that's why it's translating to your
tape talk and so now it's gotten to a
level that's unacceptable
and you need to have just more conscious
no I know and you know what it's so
crazy is that as a computer type er I'm
so efficient like and I really have
absolutely no typos that's because we
were saying like we learned to type at
such a pivotal age yet at a young age
but with my phone like I just I have fat
fingers and I just got the new iPhone
maybe that's what it there's no excuse
so your fingers are fine your nails
aren't fake like you can you can take
the time literally and every single
thing that you write there is at least
one typo more at but I'm saying like at
least one but I just like I can't be
bothered to update it like I mean you're
gonna end up with [ __ ] up takes oxygen
it's gonna flop people should just be
grateful that I'm answering their tax at
this point you know I'm a star like what
I'm saying even in like your emails no I
led my emails do not have typos no okay
no my emails do not have typos
that email from my computer from your
phone but my phone is definitely
probably attica okay well I'm glad that
you're aware the talk is highlighting
this for you yes maybe I see thank you
okay
Oh such a [ __ ] grandma Gertie's in my
grave grandma who's like used to her tic
tacs that's a good New Year's resolution
for you yeah but like I just because
it's honestly so easy you know what it
is it's like it doesn't really bother me
it bothers other people it's like do I
really care but then your messages
aren't getting across like no one's
answering your questions so it's at the
end of the day it's bothering you it's
affecting you it was just bothering me
like in that one situation but I see
what you're saying and I will I will
think about it as for my resolution I
think we just saved you a lot of time at
the end of the day unless if my
resolution is that I start budgeting
like I'm out of control
I'm out of control this is the season of
like when you spend all your money in
this January first you like stop
spending stop eating and like you trying
get your life together but like right
now I just feel like ah what's it called
like it's just a pile on you know yeah
but like I think everyone feels that way
during the season but I've been feeling
that way for like the last like 11
months okay so I don't think it's like a
seasonal thing I think it's pretty much
here to say oh well good luck good luck
with that thank you now I think that it
is time to get into our past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast do you think I do I really
really do I'm sure we have a slate of
interesting content you disagree I don't
disagree per se because I think that
would definitely be a little far you
know taking a little far saying I
disagree but I would like to give you
know brief pause here just to let
everyone know that today's episode is
brought to you by hellofresh just in
time for our New Year's resolutions oh
my gosh hello fresh is home-cooked meals
made simple they make cooking delicious
meals at home a reality regardless of
your comfort in the kitchen you know
that Jackie and I have a very low
comfort level in the kitchen
um so hellofresh gives you step-by-step
recipes with pre-measured ingredients
you'll have everything you need to get a
WoW worthy dinner on the table in just
30 minutes
say goodbye to endless grocery store
trips and take-out hellofresh has you
covered you can make delicious
deliciousness a part of your every week
break out of your dinner but with
hellofresh is 20 plus seasonal chef
curing recipes each week there's
something for everyone so Jackie and I
both have different types of palettes I
like to eat like a two-year-old
Jackie technically is vegetarian so they
have tons of different options you can
choose from
there's something for everyone they have
family recipes too calories smart
recipes and vegetarian recipes both of
which I think are more Jackie's speed
and they have fun menu Siri tech Hall of
Fame and craft burgers they have more
five-star recipes than any other male
kids so you know you'll get something
delicious they are flexible and it fits
your lifestyle you can add extra meals
to your weekly order as well as yummy
add-ons like garlic bread and cookie
dough see that's more my speed like the
carbs and the desserts you can easily
change your delivery days food
preferences and skip a week whenever you
need it's really just a premium a
premium service and if one of your new
year's resolutions is to cut back on
ordering in or just cut back um on you
know your budgeting or you want to learn
how to cook that was Jackie's resolution
this year and hellofresh definitely
helped it definitely did you can get
nine free meals with hellofresh by going
to hello fresh dot-com slash toast nine
and using the code toast nine so that's
toast and the number nine again that's
hello fresh comm slash toast nine and
the code is toast nine nine the number
not spelled out sign on and get to
cookin because I'm hungry
yes that's a great New Year's resolution
it was mine I wanna I've fallen off a
little bit I'm gonna pick back up in the
new year and hellofresh makes is so easy
it and not too intimidating to do that
um so yes that is the sponsor of today's
episode also every episode is pretty
much sponsored by the dirty jeans tour
tickets available Carlton job com I'm
gonna be in for onna New York upstate
New York near Syracuse to speaking at
the Turning Stone Casino we are going to
be turning them stones y'all but you
obviously don't have to bring your own
stone the casino will be providing for
everyone no stone is gonna be left
unturned
are you a gangster
I'm just so you know I'm really excited
about like I'm really like happy and sad
I totally get what case in West Coast is
saying that my tour is ending like I'm
really looking forward to like being
here full-time for a year like spending
time with you and just like getting back
to being a person who has a house like I
totally missed that obviously I will
miss like you know the glitz and the
glam and the money and being on tour cuz
don't get me wrong it's so much fun but
I'm not gonna miss like shelling for
tickets you know like I've done 80 shows
now it's like it's enough you know and
in the beginning like for the first like
50 shows like I never had to promote it
was just like they sold out but now it's
like people are like on their fourth
time seeing me along Paris came to my
show in Westchester and it was her sixth
show like I think now it's like the time
has come for the tour to end and I'm
just looking forward to not having to
do you like spy bugs you know ya know
it'll be the end of an era for sure they
totally will be I don't even know what
I'm gonna name my next tour we're gonna
have the toasters the toast some toaster
came up a dirty Jean store I know we did
it live on air yeah oh also I knew we
was discussion yesterday and we didn't
make a decision do we want to do the
poll that we oh yes we did oh my God
thank you for bringing it up because we
have been getting so much so many
questions about camp toast 2020 which is
Memorial Day weekend 2020 tickets lasts
previously have gone on sale over the
holidays but we have been getting some
messages that the holiday says we were
saying like are a tough time budgeting
wise for people because you have to get
gifts for everyone it's just a tough
time of year so we wanted to ask you if
you would rather tickets go on sale
before the holidays or after the highway
like the week before Christmas or
beginning of January or like January
15th like payday so where should I put a
pole we're gonna put a pole on our
Instagram story and then based on how
people vote I know it's a nice thing to
be able to get the tickets as if for
people for the holidays but if too many
people I can't get them when they want
to get them then maybe it's worth
waiting til January 15th so it's
completely your guys's choice vote in
our poll on our Instagram but regardless
camp toast 2020 is Memorial Day weekend
2020 and we are so excited I'm so
excited I was recently watching our
patreon video of kam Taos and I was like
literally crying because I wait until
tax time but that's so true okay I'm
poll why do we want camp tickets before
Christmas I've run in the live try to
saying after they're saying don't worry
say before Christmas or after actually
explicit parenthesis January yeah okay
it is on our Instagram story I see one
for before I think it's only fair
because we were going back and forth
like we were disagreeing it's like we're
not buying them like let's see what the
people want yeah so everyone just you
know voting is power rock the boat right
you have the power also that would be a
great time to remind you that everyone
should be registered to vote in their
specific States yes and register to vote
for the camco schools it's honestly the
most pressing issue of today oh so I was
watching the video and I was like
literally just like crying like I think
that the months leading up to camp
toasts are very anxiety inducing for us
and we don't get to get excited about it
and then
after it happens like now I'm like in
the point where I'm actually like really
excited for it and I just like can't
wait to go back you know live in ten
months or to living ten months for two
and obviously cam toast 1 & 2 were so
much fun and pretty much everything's
gonna be the same but we do have like a
few upgrades to be doing it's the same
format same everything but definitely
upgrades on like activities and and then
some thing that we had read that was
that like not everyone got to get a
picture with us which is so crazy
because like the way that it works it's
like just come up and take a picture but
we understand that people are shy and
introverted like myself also it is a
weird thing like I would literally never
so now we're gonna do like a little meet
and greet situation so that everybody
can get a photo with a premium lights a
premium background yeah that it's really
taken care of and you don't have to like
worry about it the whole time because I
can get I can see how that could be
stressed oh so like I think we should do
it at the beginning just like get it out
of the way so people can like live their
lives and then like not wear makeup Oh
totally you know yeah but then we love
to wear makeup like it's not a choice
well not everyone does know but a lot of
people do yeah but a lot of people don't
yeah and then they don't they know they
have a picture then they're gonna be
like running around just in case like I
mean greets that day you know that's
true yeah so the whole schedule will be
up and everything it's gonna be so
pretty sociable I'm really really
excited so stay tuned for all of that
and make sure to vote in the poll
because your voice matters it does are
you ready for our first story I mean I
cannot believe it's been 19 minutes but
yes um cardi B is on the cover of Vogue
with her daughter culture she is looking
gorge on a truly beautiful like precious
angels on the cover I love everything
about this I just stand cardi B so much
and like I love that the world stands
for two and I think there was a point in
time where Vogue like would have you
know stuck its nose up to people like
cardi B and she's just out here on the
cover and I'm glad that vobis like
finally come around to just being like
what we wanted it to be like a magazine
with celebrities on the cover you know
and then like fashion inside but like
celebrities on the cover no I just love
that cardi B in the span of two days is
in the strip club like getting the
shadow band on Instagram and on the
cover of Vogue like get you a girl who
can do did she get shadow bands yeah Wow
cuz when I went to search her it wasn't
coming up and I thought for a second I
was like dude cardi B block me but by
the way I had the same thing but it's
because her Instagram is I am cardi B
know everyone was saying that she was
shadow oh hold on I don't follow her so
let me see if I can find her and so
don't really know
no man is but it means you don't know
she this not shadow man that means you
don't come up in the search you know who
shadow band is Jacky Chimel she has been
since I met her at vital proteins
literature is Jacky SCH she doesn't come
up like if you yeah if you want to find
her and you have to go to someone's
account who follows her it's crazy so
like I follow her so you go if she's
still shadow because there's something
really weird going on with her inscribe
like some one Instagram like has it
offer so now I go to girl with no job
following now I see Jackie shambles
Instagram how crazy is that Wow and like
she's lost 10,000 followers like they're
like they're they're stewing something
to her and I got to lead what's the
cause I know they say that she like
triggered some she broke some rule when
she called all of us [ __ ] on Instagram
like she was sitting on the table she
was like look at these [ __ ] and like
was me and like Heather and mournin
Stewart like it was not when we're
actually like being [ __ ] you know maybe
they were well that's really crazy
justice for her justice for it Bucky
sucks this this cover is beautiful I
can't wait to read the article
apparently she talks a lot about how
like the hate that she gets like people
can't stand to see her winning like she
goes on Twitter and like everyone just
has something to say yeah they're just
jealous but also in like the female rap
game it's like San culture is is so
heightened like you can't just like like
all female rap music like you either are
like a Nicki Minaj or like a Remy Ma or
or a cardi B and there's so few players
in the game like it's really such a
device divisive like audience so that
when cardi B like does break records
that Nicki Minaj once held like people
hate her for it because the Nicki Minaj
stands like they're jealous like cardi B
nobody wants to say but like and it's
terrible that there can't be too and
like there can be but there can't
because Nicki Minaj and cardi B are so
competitive with one another but like
Macari B is now bigger than Nicki Minaj
got it
oh so this is a lesson for you
apparently she's in shadow band Jackie
shame all because she's always talking
about how she wants to [ __ ] her dog and
I'm just reading this in the comments I
don't know if that's true but I just
know that that is you should be me but I
don't say it on Instagram I said on my
podcast but okay but don't [ __ ] it up
don't get this podcast did she say that
that's [ __ ] hilarious that's what
that's what some people are saying I
know what she means
okay our next story is an update
yesterday story about rapper juice world
hmm because now it's come out that juice
world may have triggered his own death
when he allegedly downed pills yeah like
he was on a private plane and a police
raid the police raid to them yeah
because a couple people he was with had
guns and can't carry guns on a private
right I actually think that his um the
pilot call had called the police
yeah so I they're saying that apparently
allegedly he had a bunch of pills on him
and the police were coming so he downed
them all causing an overdose time and
death that is a terrible idea
terrible idea and rush them terrible put
them over your buttcheeks like literally
or anything like you didn't know little
trouble right oh yeah or that a little
like I don't know what they were
percocets apparently I don't terrible
way to died like oh my god like an
accident yeah oh my god that's crazy oh
my god like that's like the story just
keeps getting worse
yeah keeps getting worse so anyways
we'll update you on this story as more
things come in um but it's just a really
sad story about rising stress totally so
maybe he didn't fake his own death no no
that we're reconsidering yeah
but it's an interesting theory on
tick-tock yes tick-tock is just out here
pushing premium content by the way we
had gotten to the story four minutes ago
and we're already on our third story no
I know and I'm some story it's like
don't need deliberating they just need
reporting yeah I mean like they're just
tough like you never know like what
we're just gonna like dive into so hard
we don't even know right and what's just
gonna literally be like one sentence
like here's what happened yeah exactly
are you ready for our next sentence I
guess actually this one's pretty
interesting okay that was where it could
take us okay Julia Louie Dreyfus says
SNL was quote very sexist during her
time there wait I'm sure by the way
anyone who was made - Julia Louie
Dreyfus is evil she's the most precious
woman on planet earth mm-hmm Julia Louie
Dreyfus made the revelation Saturday
night in the sit-down with Stephen
Colbert at a packed fundraiser for his
wife's film and arts organization at the
New Jersey Performing Arts Center where
I will be performing bergenpac
tickets available Walker oh wow quote
there were plenty of people on the show
who were incredibly funny she said about
working on SNL but quote I was
unbelievably naive
didn't really understand how the
dynamics of the police worked it was
very sexist very sexist yeah the actress
also spoke to what she said was rampant
drug use among lovers on the NBC show
who was she on with I'm gonna Google I
don't even I don't like if you had asked
me what Julia Louie Dreyfus was on I
would never have remembered that she was
on SNL but it makes sense that's how she
got her start but what cast was she a
part of you know oh I'm not sure she
said people were doing crazy drugs at
the time on SNL I was oblivious I just
thought oh wow he's got a lot of energy
I don't know how anybody could work
stoned
it was a pretty brutal time but it was
very informative for me she said she
appeared alongside actors who would
later rise to prominence Eddie Murphy
Jim Belushi Billy Crystal and Martin
Short I should see Martin Short doing
drugs but like you never know no but I
think she meant staffers like writers
and writing on the stars I don't think
that you can really like me I mean
actually you probably can but I don't
think she was referring to the stars I
think there are so many people who work
on the show that we don't know I
understand that like showbiz is
notoriously like you know um is
notorious for its like drug use and drug
enabling and they don't really
understand because like honestly most of
the people that I know in Hollywood like
they work so [ __ ] hard like how do you
have time to do drugs I don't know like
when I think of letting their some drugs
that like help you do your job that's
true like cocaine gives you energy right
yeah but I think when it comes to like
drinking you just have I guess you're
one of those people who doesn't get a
hangover like right cuz like if the
conspiracy theory that Jimmy Fallon is
always drunk is actually true like he
does a show every day and they has to
like rehearse the show practice show in
front of a live audience like how is
that actually possible like it actually
containable it can't be possible I don't
know you know like I was just thinking
about it cuz now I don't really drink
but I realized I only drink when I'm on
vacation because that way if I get
hungover I'm not gonna like lose
important days I'm just embedding out
doing nothing but like as a working
person like I just can't drink no
totally and I have found that like the
more like successful you become the less
you want to drink on weekends honestly
like a year ago two years ago like I
would have been balls deep to the wall
at TBG Awards like yeah but that's just
not like our life anymore and when you
like like your job and like you find
success like you want to get up the next
morning and you want to do it so I just
don't even understand and I guess that's
more of like an addiction mindset that I
can't really relate to you but I can't
understand like having so much success
like when I think of like you know works
so [ __ ] much and by the way never
complains Kelly Clarkson Olivia culpo
she is on a plane every day and you know
she's an influencer and like at heart
and influencers love to be like just
gotta have a plan like I'm exhausted
like people like love to complain it's
like that Lauren Elizabeth has a perfect
word for it it's like it's like a
Hustler's what's it called
I'm sure she's listening to his podcast
screaming at her radio it's a brilliant
it's like way to describe it should I
text her yeah
and basically what she what she says it
it's like influencers especially like
young people on the Internet are like
always complaining about like their job
and how busy they are and like their
meetings and it's like at the end of the
day like we're so blessed and grateful
to be to be exhausted that I just hate
when people complain about and I know I
do it sometimes on my Instagram and I
try me really conscious of it I just
like [ __ ] hate when people do it and
Lorne Elizabeth has the perfect word for
it yeah it's like I just texted her
hustle okay we'll get to it but anyways
I so agree with you about Olivia culpo
like and bad girls on a plane every
single day doing she's on sets all night
doing night shoots and she has never
complained and she definitely doesn't do
drugs no she at she couldn't she
couldn't that's what I think I think she
gets no more than like 4 hours of sleep
a night except for when like she goes
home to Rhode Island
like she literally wakes up at 5:00 a.m.
for something not just cuz she wakes up
like for something new either get a
plane to get to a set like always doing
something she does like multiple things
every single day and she also has to
look snatch doing it at all time right
it's crazy like she went to Atlanta and
she was doing like Miss Universe or Miss
USA or something and it's like I
understand like you work hard and you
could be tired but like it's like every
night is the TPG Awards for her no
literally and like I'm exhausted from
just sitting and glam yesterday that was
the most exhausting thing ever know and
like the three days leading up I was
just like having to be really conscious
of what I ate and it's like now today I
can eat whatever I want but it's like no
today she has another GPG no totally
like she's the hardest working woman in
showbiz and I'm glad for all of her
success yeah also she hosted Miss
Universe and I know we can talk about
Miss Universe yesterday but I want to
mention two things did you see that
Steve Harvey had another misstep where
he announced like I mean like it was an
award that wasn't a part of like a Miss
Congeniality and in the teleprompter
they were at the wrong name and he was
like these people are trying to set me
up to be really funny now you saw who I
think it was how that for know who won
Miss Universe now Miss America know Miss
Teen u.s. miss us
Miss America and Miss Universe are all
black oh wow is that cool that's awesome
yeah I read that this morning I'm bummed
they didn't get to watch the show me too
I love a pageant and I know they're like
outdated and like a little out of touch
but like I don't know there's something
really glamorous about them and I really
don't care no I mean there it is but
like okay right it's every woman's
choice it's that right exactly also if
someone called it a busy brag that's not
what Lauren called oh but that is that
is a good term for it - yeah it's like a
humble brag almost like I'm so busy I
was just chatting around the world like
it's so annoying yeah but I want to
figure out the word she's Lord Elizabeth
his on La time so I don't know if she's
like yeah and she's gonna be so confused
like why were texting her in the middle
of the show yeah okay anyways our next
story is about the Art Basel banana and
it's brought to you by a new game I'm
I'm obsessed with playing games everyone
knows that I'm a board game freak and I
love playing games on my phone and I
especially love playing games on my
phone that don't require internet so I
can play it on the plane you can play it
on a train you can play it on the subway
it's called best friend stars it's
bright and explosive puzzles with snappy
and colorful graphics the characters are
so cute is a very casual game that
anyone can play but it's made for adults
you can spend as much time or as little
time as you'd like in the game I so it's
free to download which is the best part
and that what most games don't have is
that you can play it without internet
which is so crazy I didn't even know
that was a thing
it's a snappy quick and rewarding
experience you can smash their way
through puzzles with super fun
explosions and collect tons of you cute
fun characters along the way they update
the game monthly with new levels events
and characters so it never gets old they
treat the game like a service for their
players there is no internet required to
play it it's great for traveling whether
you're on a plane subway or you're just
bored at work which we know some of
these are you can use boosters it's a
fun mechanic that players collect to
help beat levels you can engage with
other players by joining a team or
teammates help each other or even
compete against other teams I just love
a good phone game um I also love down
downloading phone games on my iPad and
then on a plane it's just like a really
premium experience this is a great game
for you guys I in like the game kind of
sailor so like if I'm you know Jeffrey
star gets his approval like on a
concealer like I give my approval on a
game Monopoly check best friends puzzle
check I spare you guys to like it it's a
great game and then you know when you
play a game so much that you play it in
your sleep yes so I have been playing
this game of my
sleep because like when you I guess it's
simply like a brain thing that I cannot
represent but it's like I'm moving the
puzzles well it's so crazy it's weather
that freaks me out yeah you can match
and bless your way through explosive
puzzles and collect tons of cute
characters there's even a fun social
feature that allows you to team up with
friends and family
download best friends stars for free on
the Apple Store on Apple or on Google
Play it is free to download again that's
best friends stars for free on the Apple
App Store or Google Play
check it out free to download don't need
internet check it out Bryan to the Art
Basel banana applicants are wanting to
talk about the fact that kit Chris and
Katie from matram Harrod ice broke up
they broke the news this morning in an
Instagram caption that they both copy
and pasted from each other and posted
premium pictures this is the least
shocking thing ever if you saw them on
the bachelor in paradise they say I was
shocked to find out they were still
together I saw this story before we went
live this morning and I just like didn't
think it was news ya know and I also
like didn't really care because if you
knew anything about them like you knew
they weren't meant to last so as much as
this was just a matter of man asleep
dragged it out really [ __ ] long good
for them I hope they made all the money
that you can make as a post bachelor
engage couple so now we only have
Hanna G and Dylan left right uh
Christian and Demi officially broken up
I believe so do they put him Instagram
out I think so
okay I think I heard on this matter well
we we broke the story like weeks before
on the toast because obviously we break
everything burst I think there's one
other couple that's still together
yeah oh notation JPJ oh yeah know if
they do Steve together there were three
engage couples oh yeah that's that's
Akana yeah how does she and Dillon are
so [ __ ] cute like they're so real and
it makes me think like they really
edited it to being like she knows
affiliation right yeah and not even
consolation prize she chose him because
she wanted to like look good right but
now just like watching their life
together in LA like they're so cute
she's still the most beautiful woman on
the planet and he's so hot and like
respects the hell out of her and I just
really enjoy following them yeah and
though she said
ganache yeah they're really cute and if
you want to know more about what's going
on listen to the snatchler it's the
premium bachelor podcast hosted by the
snitch
yep okay now the art basil banana
because the new owners of the banana are
speaking out about their purchase of the
banana
you heard update where the man ate the
banana
yeah honestly what they're saying I
guess as an art person like I'm not that
they are makes a little bit of sense we
are acutely aware of the blatant
absurdity of the fact that comedian
which is the name of the piece is an
otherwise inexpensive and perishable
piece of produce and a couple of inches
of duct tape when we saw the public
debate sparked about art and our society
we decided to purchase it we knew we
were taking a risk but ultimately we
sense that Catalans banana will become
an iconic historical object known
honestly saaphyri moment that's like
silly and stupid it's just a meme also
the piece was sabotage by the
performance artists who ate it and
robbed Weber who spent it who
spray-painted Epstein didn't kill
himself
across the wall where the banana had
been um well that's so funny he also
spelled Epstein wrong oh no they
compared it the owners compare it to
Andy Warhol's Campbell's soup can saying
that people laughed at the now iconic
work when it first emerged and said they
plan to eventually donate it to a museum
I don't understand what part of this
that they could donate them but here's
the thing just like the main difference
between um Andy Warhol and this piece is
that Andy Warhol's piece wasn't
perishable right you didn't have a blank
soup sitting there right so John this
thing I've ever heard it was a painting
if it was a painting of a banana I would
think so think it was stupid but less
stupid it's stupid and they were sayin
dazed culture like yes it's become a big
deal and it's it's a lot of the food for
thought literally um but in a week it's
gonna be meaningless and I think art
means more than that like this is just
like a funny headline meme I don't know
yeah and their explanation for spending
so much money on this dumb perishable
piece of art was that while technically
it is perishable they own now like the
the artistic idea and the banana is
meant to be replaced once it goes
spoiled okay Lee and it's cool that they
own the idea I mean at the TV geo word
someone had a banana taped to their back
and so it's obviously legs like a funny
taking the world by storm but like for
one week tops mark my words and then now
you spend to $120,000 on a joke on a
joke just to get your name in page six
which honestly
cheap at the price it's not that easy to
get your name in paychecks trust me I've
tried okay are you ready for our fifth
and final story no through the middle
story it's a little bit of
business I know this story and I'm shook
by it and I would like you to read it in
full okay
the CEO of luggage company away steps
down after being accused of fostering a
toxic work environment the CEO of the
incredibly popular luggage brand away is
stepping down after being accused of
fostering a toxic work environment yes
we've heard last week the verge
published a report documenting Stephanie
Corey's harsh treatment toward away
employees in 2018 in the article away
employees complained of the company's
click like nature being forced to work
exceedingly long hours and being
severely scrutinized for making mistakes
despite the brands mission of
inclusivity and togetherness away staff
members alleged they were also
instructed to only communicate the slack
an instant messaging platform and were
prohibited from emailing each other
email was only used to discuss small
matters like asking someone where they
wanted to eat lunch according to the
Verge's report slack was where most
business matters were discussed that is
Solio the root of some of away's issues
I guess they wanted people to
communicate like in public chats and
slack so you're not like emailing people
on the side talking like you know
talking about work you know screengrab
shared in the verges reports show corey
slamming an employee as being quote
brain-dead
we're not correctly monogramming at
customers luggage away employees
explained in the report that queries
critical feedback was often done in
slack channels with other employees
making the occurrences all the more
humiliating according to the report
corey also temporarily took away not
away capital a took away paint time off
and work from home privileges from a
waste customer experience team saying
it'll quote help their career
development quote i know this group is
hungry for career development
opportunities and an effort to support
you in developing your skills i'm going
to help you learn the career a scale of
accountability she wrote in a slack
message she went on to explain that no
new paid time off or work from home
request would be approved quote until we
reach five context consecutive days of
all our attempts to reach CX on live
platforms being successful so she was
the CEO and the co-founder not the
co-founder she just so it was a hired
CEO yes because the two women who
started away are like boss [ __ ] they
both have the same name i think i think
it's like two girls named sarah
okay um so okay so it's not the founder
just like a hired CEO that just sucks
you want to know why cuz like I feel
like it's already there so few female
CEOs and now this is just gonna be like
the next time you know some woman gets
passed over for a job they like well
look at the other women see every way
like she couldn't handle it but like
this woman's insane
yeah they already brought in a new CEO
from Lululemon I believe it's a woman so
okay that's great yeah I just I wonder
if it would have been made such a big
deal like this is such a big news story
and like what she what her size her
[ __ ] evil
no any wonder if it would have been such
like a big story if it wasn't a woman do
you know what I mean oh I think so
because honestly what she wrote it's
like those sorority emails I mean it's
so mean but also she's using like office
jargon to couch everything because on
the surface it's not like she's using
crazy words like [ __ ] [ __ ] right like
what the [ __ ] yeah so it's so
interesting because office jargon is
[ __ ] hilarious and it's crazy that
like slack is like this centre of this
storm because it's such a big thing in
office places and like smack is being
used it's like a tool for bullying it's
crazy you know and this is like the
worst advertisement for [ __ ] actually
it's not the worst advertisement I've
ever seen first lack because there used
to be a slew of subway ads like in Penn
Station at first lack and it was the
dumb it was like a mock a slack
conversation and it was so confusing oh
my god he's like take pictures of it all
the time it's always coming up in my
time hop so this isn't the worst
advertisement I've ever seen for a sec
but also just like a weird lies the
co-founder oh it is Oh shucks just a
weird what a weird flex like I don't
know a lot about business but I know
that email is pretty much like a great
form of communication and I don't really
understand why you would get rid of it
to contribute to your company culture no
because she was contributing to a
culture of like you can't talk to your
fellow employees god forbid there was
like employee camaraderie everyone needs
to work from the silo and just focus on
the work and don't talk to anyone else
about anything else I always think like
when these kinds of stories come out
about companies what does it like at
work today you know is it awkward or is
it like a joyous occasion right well
she's gone so it's like dingdong the
witch is dead
yes I think it's like a celebration but
I always wonder when like big companies
are like being dragged for like it for
like internal
in like a public media like what happens
at work that day I think it's pretty
normal and sure everyone's just talking
about it
right it's probably like like fun like
you're irrelevant yeah and you're
getting justice yes
you know like honestly the day that we
got fired from oh it's like I wonder
what oath was like we weren't there
because we got fired but like it was
probably late ablaze everyone talking
about they were always like being
dragged through the news because it was
like the saddest little company trying
to stay relevant it make sure every
article that ever like we were just like
small we were in the smallest of
scandals because really because I
thought we were know like everyone said
well there would be like a huge thing
just talking about like how o'the
Verizon like AOL is just beyond [ __ ]
sad yeah and like losing money and it's
just hilarious okay so that's good we're
not that big of a mean I don't think we
missed much and like I wouldn't even
they really talk to us so totally so
like I don't think we affected anyone's
day-to-day how'd you miss the free lunch
though they really had great snacks went
with a soda machine
ah yes yeah yeah but when we build our
media company we'll have a soda machine
also apparently the Lululemon CEO is a
man so I just got that all backwards oh
no so sad so sad it's about to be 11:11
and which reminded me about the
Gabrielle Union story she is just um
so many people are coming out and
supporting her and I'm seeing her
retweet them on Twitter and it's just
like nice to see that women being
supported you know what enough I still
never heard of o'the in my life oh yeah
actually I think oath itself did get I
the name is gone it was like a rebrand
and then I think they rebranded again oh
also uh I'm sure everyone is wondering
oh I mean a way did used to sponsor the
show but not anymore so we're free to uh
dragon yeah it's 11:11 make a wish I
wish for you know peaceful work
environments for pretty much everyone I
wish that everyone has a Merry Christmas
and a happy holiday oh um you know we
haven't done a wild meal because we kind
of wrapped up early we haven't taken
questions from YouTube look we haven't
done like our own little Q&A and really
lunch I mean we rarely do because that's
like but we should do it we should do it
if you're on YouTube feel free to drop a
question for us because I just feel like
there's a lot of stones unturned you
know people want to hear from us a stone
unturned you better [ __ ] turn it this
weekend all right a Verona New York
tickets available I girl throw job calm
that's
just gonna be like so iconic I know it I
can't believe like us ticking about
maybe not coming I know I have to
rethink it's whether you could just
casually just like where your fabletics
leggings and just like rocks I love my
fab land exciting me too if a blood X
was born in 2013 everyone knows it's
co-founded by the Queen Kate Hudson the
founding team was noticed that a large
disparity in the activewear marketplace
it was very difficult to find trendy
stylish gym wear that was priced
affordably and fabletics came to the
rescue
I love my fabletics items but my
favorite thing is seeing fabletics
partners on Instagram and watching what
other people get like how they style it
like I watch Kelty nights um Instagram
story is like a few weeks ago and she
just did such a great haul and there's
so many pieces and so many things to
choose from that it's actually really
cool to see what other people choose um
so if you want to get into fabletics if
you like wearing workout clothes you
like working out or you just like
wearing the clothes you can take a quick
60 second style pop quiz for your
personalized outfit recommendations then
you shop from thousands of styles
curated just for you you can check out
us a guest or become a VIP and there's
tons of VIP perks like up to 50% off of
regular prices free shipping and
additional perks there uh so I suggest
signing up for a VIP I get emails all
the time about like what kind of offers
they have going on and actually is
definitely worth umm worth the cost FEHB
buttocks is your one-stop shop for
affordable athletic where they have yoga
running yoga running gym gear sports
bras shoes accessories and more Snitch
swears by their Sports threads and you
know that girl has big jugs oh yeah I
love their sports bras and leggings and
they have the cutest little sets so that
way when you're filming yourself in the
gym like it's less sad because you're
being cute with fabletics if you're
anxious to get in shape and feel
confident stepping into your workout
routines try trendy and affordable gym
where we highly recommend checking out
fabletics and trust us you do not want
to miss out on their very special offer
you can get to leggings for only $24
it's a $99 value and you only get that
if you sign up for VIP so be sure to
check out all of our favorite leggings
when they're in stock as designs can
change monthly all you have to do is go
to fabletics calm flush toast to take
advantage of this deal now that's
fabletics dot-com slash toast to get to
leggings for only $24 that is fabletics
comm slash toast the best part is that
there's no commitment to purchase
monthly and free shipping on all orders
over $49 so make sure you enter your
email address when you take the style
quiz as you'll receive exclusive
discounts
and the inside scoop about new
collections that haven't been released
yet go to fabletics dot-com / toast
again that's fabletics stockholm / toast
terms and conditions may apply love it
are we getting good question getting
really good questions I think I'll go
through them
okay so I'll put my um okay there and
then then let's also check the status of
our poll oh okay but also it's gonna be
like a day long thing most people listen
at Sepang usually something comes
through like immediately yeah any time
they do a poll like whatever the first
like answer in the first minute is it
pretty much stays true so right now
we're like but maybe the podcasters will
filled in 1734 after camp
I mean after Christmas for okay good to
know I mean it's the same to us also
there was a question in here will
patreon members get early access and yes
for all events patreon members get early
access so if you want to ensure that you
got a camp to his ticket patreon.com
slash the morning toast
are you ready yep I don't even know like
where I love a Q&A where to start
whatever holiday plans a lot of
questions about that
oh I'm spending December with Ben's
family we are going away to the
Caribbean Oh fun I'm spending December
Break with Zach's family you're also
going away should be ready in should we
hang out oh my god maybe we should
Island top I see you across
across the ocean also someone asked a
question about our schedule for the
holidays we are last show of the year
will be next Thursday December 19th and
then we'll be back live the first Monday
in January so that's gonna be crazy yeah
um what do you guys think of all the
savage comments Farabi also I just want
to talk about yesterday's episode oh my
god yeah we didn't even recap the siesta
key kid so I actually have met Robbie a
bunch of times and he's been so
incredibly nice and like yeah he's a
thirst monster but like so are we like
who are we to judge one thirst monster
from another I was actually really
shocked at how many comments that just
their social card got on our Instagram
dissipation of the four of them asking
for questions got almost a thousand
comments and like 70% of them were about
Robbie being thirsty and I felt bad for
him and I was glad that you had asked
him that question and I thought his
answer was like kind of genuine and nice
um so I don't feel the way about him
that everyone does well it's Miran
because when I see him like obviously
he's on Siesta Key and you watch the
first episode and it's like he you
assume he has a nefarious intentions or
you just look at his instagramming
assume he's thirsty but then when you
see
meet him he's just a regular guy in
total there's something about the way he
comes off like behind a screen that
makes him like seem like the thirstiest
Ken doll of all time like yeah
unapproachable but he I don't know why
he gets that grab more than anyone else
who's done exactly what he Rose been on
bachelor nation like so it's weird I
agree and I felt bad cloudy and Jackie
what is your biggest pet peeve I hate
when people eat salad and then leave
salad dressing in the corners of their
mouths like you know when they're eating
and you could just like see the white
like crustacean in their inner corners
oh yeah what do I you um I would say
generally speaking my biggest pet peeve
is repeating myself like when I say
something and either you didn't hear or
you were just shocked didn't you say
what and like I have to say it again I
don't know why yeah like something in me
I'm like I know that I'm not saying it
again yeah it's because it's a Groot if
someone's not listening the first time
unless I didn't actually hear you like
like look I miss understand but even
that like bothers me or if there's like
I don't know I just hate repeating
myself yeah also a pet peeve that's like
been bothering me recently on the
Internet is just like people comment
like saying things as if they're fast
like oh my god jackknife I don't see why
it's just like really bothering me like
when people just say stuff as if they
know something especially when it's
about me right exactly you're a public
figure people like think they know
things about either like I heard her
cousins brother ad said that she was a
[ __ ] like and they just like then speak
on you like they know you for fact and
they speak on things like they're 100%
true it bothers me so much I'm like
what's crazy as we do like this show an
hour a day like you guys know you do
know so much about us and like so like
but then you still find like ways to
make things up as if they're fact and
right oh my god I see it happen in the
toaster script people like speaking
about me like they I heard she did this
shut up [ __ ] no you don't you don't
know anything um she'd kind Kim get TMT
PR packages no I [ __ ] wish I [ __ ]
wish I don't even know where to
something I didn't even talk about on
the show how I got the Kylie holiday
yeah and you did such premium content
rather repost you know she didn't Kylie
cosmetics no and honestly I was so
deceased I don't know what if I could
have handled a remor yeah and I wasn't
really looking for him because honestly
it was such an honor like I have been
out here like buying Kylie cosmetics
since day one every like drop I set an
alarm
like I have a whole collection of hide
of cosmetics I've donated so many
Kyler's cosmetics to like fuel my
addiction and to like be recognized and
like when I got it was just it came in
like a plain box and when I opened it I
saw there was confetti and I was like oh
like one of our sponsor Santa's well
anything and he picked it up and it said
Kylie and I literally I was alone and
like my jaw dropped I started screaming
I like said how much was in there oh my
god it was so good it was so premium the
collections amazing like I really would
have bought like so much of that stuff
and it just really felt wonderful to be
recognized do you think there's any
stuff in there like you wouldn't want
but like a chubby olive skin toned girl
well for sure okay because we really do
have like different colors when it comes
to makeup Oh what are you going to get
your significant other for Hanukkah um
I'm just over getting people gifts I'm
not gonna lie like I haven't gotten been
a gift and so long and it's so mean but
it's like I'd rather get him one gift a
year that's more of like a more
substance and has more meaning than like
anniversary Valentine's Day Chanukah
like birthday four or five like smaller
gifts you know yeah I agree unless they
see something I'm like oh that has to
have it and I can mask it as a Hanukkah
gift and honestly because right because
we don't celebrate Christmas like
holiday gifts are not really a thing
like when we were a kid it was like
eight days like yeah we would get like a
little toy every day but as adults like
there's no Christmas shopping for us
because Hanukkah is like not really a
thing like fur gifts yeah it was when
you were kids but best thing to do in
New York for Christmas um stay inside
and go to Radio City Music Hall pursue
the Rockettes the Christmas Spectacular
can also go ice skating
like down the block at Rockefeller
Center there's a lot of cool things now
that they're doing like there's a glues
on rooms and like all these like yeah
fake like apres-ski stuff that we don't
do Christmas in New York anymore like
all the touristy stuff because we've
done it for so long but I feel like now
there's actually really cool things that
I kind of want to try like hotels doing
cool yeah and also like there is a
stereotype that New York during
Christmas is like mayhem no an it is but
no but on actually that Christmas Day
December 25th 26 it's actually very
quiet and it's really peaceful so if you
are a New Yorker who usually leaves
during Christmas if you're gonna stay
it's actually quite lovely like it's
pretty does empty out people do things
like with their families on Christmas
like there they go out to the suburbs so
it's pretty quiet and it's actually
really nice
it's camp toast something you can go to
solo
yes I would say most people show up solo
or some people show up with like a
friend or sister and they end up like
spending time apart because they just
like meet different people and I was so
yeah I was rewatching our patreon video
and we did like little testimonials with
campers both first year campers and
second year campers being like what was
your favorite part of camp and almost
everyone said was the people like making
so many friends that like I came here
alone I didn't know anyone and like I
have friends that like we take trips
together now with like these friendships
like I know will last a lifetime
so like the people is really what draws
people to camp I would say like the fun
good vibes too but the people really
trust campers in and I think people are
usually really surprised that when they
come alone like it doesn't feel weird ah
totally and they think being forced so I
get out of your comfort zone actually
might have like it's nice to go with a
friend I'm sure and it's easy but you
might like learn things about yourself
and have a better time than you could
even imagine if you come alone so I
highly recommend coming alone as an
adult there are very few situations
where you need to rely on like that
making new friends like as a kid like
you got to school or you transfer to
camp or there was always situations
where you have to like go in alone and
make new friends but you don't get a lot
of things like that as an adult because
you just do whatever you want no so cam
toast is a new experience for a lot of
people and I think it's great to get out
of your comfort zone um
wait this was a great question uh-oh
what are your goals for the toast in
2020 Kati Pastore camp toaster I had a
list of goals on my phone for this year
oh you did yeah let's see if we did any
of them okay but it was for like me and
you show the weekend got it media
partner for the toast like we're working
on it yeah we we just had one xfinity oh
that's so true oh my god okay um my next
show in New York to be at Radio City so
we'll see and being on an episode of
comedians and cars I don't think I've
gotten any closer and some sort of
comedy special we'll see we'll see very
exciting is cam toes 21 and over yes
only very strict and it's pertinent that
it stays that way otherwise we can't
have an open bar and I think all the
other campers would would be very upset
so for your safety yeah it has to be 21
plus um where's your toasters let's do
it tomorrow
let's do tomorrow when stitch was
working here as our PA she
keeping us on track every Wednesday
sending us to your toasters but that is
our fault so we will do one tomorrow
because Samaras Wednesday and that's
when we usually do it
the email is dear toasters at gmail.com
if you want to write in it's totally
anonymous we get questions you know all
types from like wedding friends bar
mitzvahs to family drama to work drama
whatever you got totally um a lot of
people are asking for like a toast live
now that like once the live show okay
yeah we can we can look into that for
you guys
very fun is there an award show red
carpet that would be a dream for you
guys to be on um like honestly I don't
know if there would be an award show
that I would get as excited about as the
CMAs but like probably the Grammys cuz
they're feeling like not that serious
yeah or like billboards are fun yeah
anything really we can really make
anything work we can make that trip
bring us to Art Basel like we'll figure
it out yeah what kind of carpet to stand
on and stream
oh who are you guys's style icons what a
dumb question I have so many I just take
little elements from everyone like
obviously today it's ariana grande in my
by the way this is a new merch it's
available now on this shot morning toast
calm and it's the cutest sweatshirt ever
I'm just gonna show please everyone
obviously twirl I'm wearing a large per
usual but I just love a hoodie me too we
don't have that many hoodies we know we
do next
so this is like obviously the toaster
supreme iam vibe and it's lit shot more
neato it's calm I'm like really trying
to think of my style icon is and I feel
like I'm my own style icon is there
anyone like you look at on Instagram and
you're like inspired and obviously no
that's like so no that's so not me I
don't really I'm not easily inspired
yeah I'm like too cynical
anyway um like I have a million like
ariana cher Horowitz Kylie Jenner Kim
Kardashian
Kacey Musgraves great lot of teacher
characters really like Elle Woods just
anyone I've ever seen in the movie you
know one who like wore pink yeah nice
house
exactly plenty vibes all the way but
then also I don't write um okay what
else what do you guys want for Christmas
um just some peace and quiet you know
time a Theo to be honest I just want I
want more affection from Theo
I'm being really honest I'm not getting
enough I'm not in a perverse way
Instagram okay I will let him know that
please okay a lot of people getting
excited for camp toast
I'm good at that make sure to head over
to our Instagram vote in our poll let us
know when you want tickets to go on sale
I mean we'll heed your request we love
you guys so much thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please subscribe give this
video a thumbs up leave a comment if you
want we are also available as a podcast
pretty much anywhere podcasts can be
found so that's the Apple Store that's a
Spotify stitcher I Heart Radio cashbox
public radio all those apps sweet if why
does it seem like you guys have been
arguing a lot on the show one had win
we're good we're good we're good we cool
we cool but if maybe I'll go back and
watch and see it did me maybe we
disagreed I don't know we agree on
everything so whenever we actually don't
disagree it's like wait what and we just
like don't know how to handle it was
there any TV on last night no no tonight
yeah yeah okay och it'll be recapping
tomorrow thank you guys so much have an
amazing day we will see you tomorrow bye
you